puede que no sea la riviera francesa
pero para los parisinos y ya es
suficiente parís playa está de regreso
en la capital francesa para el verano
mientras las orillas del río sena se
transforman en playas artificiales dando
la sensación a sus residentes de la
ciudad de una necesaria escapada al mar
de verdad es como una ruptura con la
idea de que aquí todo el mundo corre por
todos lados una cerveza con amigos es lo
máximo es bonito para los parisinos que
no pueden salir de vacaciones en verano
es perfecto con sillas cómodas y arena
seis piscinas han sido acordonadas en el
sena para que el público la disfrute y
si una playa no es para usted está el
lago artificial de la villette en el
noreste de la ciudad con temperaturas
por encima de los 30 grados celsius en
los próximos días
parís playa intenta dar un respiro a los
parisinos y a los turistas frente al
calor
es una muy buena idea porque el agua
refresca un poco y asombra gracias a las
sombrillas además las sillas son cómodas
hay cerveza no necesita nada más este
año se podrá disfrutar de la playa
parisina hasta el 21 de agosto